let's just bring you the latest figures  that are coming from the Department of  Health for the UK's overall figures for  coronavirus we've had all the individual  countries have announced their numbers  in the last couple of hours but now of  the Department of Health saying that as  of this morning three hundred and eighty  two thousand six hundred fifty tests  have been carried out fourteen thousand  nine hundred and eighty-two  the day before of those tests three  hundred and two thousand ninety three  thousand have tested positive so of the  around 300,000 or so tests that have  been carried out ninety three thousand  tested positive and of those  hospitalized in the UK now overall  twelve thousand 107 have sadly died  that's an increase of 778 from yesterday  the majority of those in England but  that is now the number gone up by 778  overall across the whole of the UK  because of Koba 19 the total now 12,000  107